vamos a partir con una pequeña encuesta
que saben de pisco y pisco pocas
respuestas para la pregunta que el mejor
barman de francia 2015 puso sus colegas
en este auditorio
sobre el pico
la oficina de promoción de parís nos
invitó un taller para aprender sobre la
vida nacional y transmitirles tres
recetas de cóctel con el espirituoso
peruano
es un aguardiente de vino pero no es
envejecido en barriles de roble
cuando uno lo asocia con el pisco sour
al limón verde o al azúcar son perfumes
que gustan y funcionan bien y places
imac serbia
quiero
asocia demonial en la
nunca de los incas rosario cree que el
éxito de la gastronomía peruana en el
mundo debe impulsar la expansión de esta
bebida que nació hace más de 400 años el
país se exporta apenas algunos millones
de dólares en parte porque es aún una
industria artesanal con más de 500
pequeñas marcas familiares el principal
mercado en el pisco del mundo son los
eeuu tenemos bastante presencia de
restaurant peruanos tenemos la diáspora
peruana distribuidores peruanos allá
asimismo tenemos en europa españa como
principal consumidor no francia se ubica
en el segundo puesto en europa sin
embargo el dinamismo que muestra francia
como demandante de nuestra espirituosa
es realmente importante en otras
iniciativas prom perú hermano a la
ciudad de pisco por la de coña que en
francia y organiza cada año la parís
pisco with para elegir el mejor pisco
sour y cóctel original hecho con el
centenario destilado